[Musica]
[Applauso]
fate un respiro profondo
ora potete chiudere gli occhi e
immaginare
immaginate quella cosa che avreste
sempre voluto fare tutti abbiamo un
sogno nel cassetto che sta lì nascosto o
quel piccolo desiderio che teniamo lì
perché non abbiamo mai avuto tempo di da
dedicargli bene ora avete l'occasione di
poter realizzare ciò che vi sta a cuore
siete pronti siete carichi siete
preparati avete tutta la voglia per
mettervi in gioco bene partiamo adesso
vi chiedo di portare la vostra mente
quella volta che avete fatto una fatica
enorme ma una fatica così non l'avete
mai più provata in tutta la vostra vita
cioè la testa che diventa pesante
pesante il fiato il fiato che manca
manca il male le braccia non ce la fate
più ma dovete andare avanti non è ancora
finita quelli dovete andare avanti
dovete resistere non si può mollare
adesso
bene ce l'abbiamo fatta ora rilasciate v
rilassatevi come come fate alla sera
sotto sotto la doccia dell'acqua calda
oppure al mattino quando siete in un
giorno di vacanza e
potete dormire un po di più ho tutto
quello che potevate fare
l'avete fatto e non c'è più niente che
vi preoccupi c'è solamente questo
momento di di sollievo di meraviglioso
sollievo
bene adesso mentre riaprite gli occhi vi
racconto la storia di una bambina di una
bambina di 8 anni che più o meno in
questo periodo dell'anno la fine maggio
inizio giugno
finiva la seconda elementare e intanto
finiva anche il corso di nuoto che stavo
facendo da più o meno un anno ne va
imparato a stare a galla fare le prime
bracciate e come ogni corso che si
rispetti alla fine e cioè c'è la gara
c'è la prima sua gara di nuoto per si
mette il costume nuovo tutto contento
perché dice un po agitata però non ho
mai fatte legare per ora tutta e curiosa
e curiosa perché dice cecenia mamma che
mi guarda c'è mio papà c'è mio fratello
ci sono i miei compagni
ce la voglio fare bene al fischio si
butta in acqua comincia a nuotare
nuotare nuotare sempre più forte le
braccia le gambe sempre più forte fino a
che pro mamma mia ma quando finisce
questa vasca non ce la faccio più non ce
la faccio più spero che finisca presto
perché poi diventa sempre più dura
l'acqua è fredda ma non le importa
continua a votare nuotare sempre di più
e sempre più fino a che ho finalmente
tocca al muro è arrivata senza fiato
alza la testa e cieli il suo istruttore
che le dice se ho visto che ti sei
impegnato molto sia stata non è volato
sino alla fine sono proprio contento
però se arrivata ultima la bimba si
rimane parecchio male cioè la fatica del
genere
poi dice anche mia mamma e che figura
mio fratello appena fatto magari
arrivato primo io l'ho amata ultima poi
mamma mia mi sono impegnata tanto ci
vede
delusione dopo qualche minuto e cioè la
premiazione come in tutte le gare che si
rispettino vengono premiati il primo il
secondo e il terzo poi l'istruttore si
avvicina e così all'improvviso la
bambina si sente mettere al collo una
medaglia una medaglia e lei più che
contenta è stupita perché immagino che
anche voi vi stiate chiedendo una
medaglia all'ultimo classificato ma
quando mai neanche nei sogni più
americani possibile è successa questa
cosa
e infatti anche lei chiede al suo
istruttore ma perché perché la medaglia
me e lui le dice ascolta gygera quella
gira quella medaglia che dietro c'è la
soluzione è infatti dietro
sull'altro lato della medaglia sul retro
c'è scritto alla tua costanza e al tuo
impegno il tuo istruttore quel giorno
quella bambina si è portata a casa non
una medaglia un oggetto così un oggetto
metallico da esibire ma non solo quello
si è portato a casa 11 degli
insegnamenti più grandi cioè che la
costanza e l'impegno premiano sempre e
come avete più o meno potuto capire
quella bambina ero io ero io che
forte di questa di questa prima
sconfitta ho capito che non è vincere
che importa ma è mettercela tutta
tant'è che ho continuato a nuotare
l'anno successivo ho fatto di nuovo la
gara di fine corso senza avere paura di
riprovarci sono arrivata quinta su
cinque però che le cose siano migliorate
molto subito però come dice il mio
allenatore e l'acqua se ti arrendi poi a
fondo se continua muoverti qualcosa
qualcosa succederà infatti in tutti
questi anni ho continuato a nuotare o
continuato notare perché è la cosa che
mi piace di più in assoluto
e adesso vi faccio riprovare un po
quelle quelle emozioni che abbiamo
provato prima
la fatica la motivazione ma soprattutto
la soddisfazione di avere messo tutto
quello che avevate ve le faccio
riprovare un'altra volta però stavolta
non dovete chiudere gli occhi anzi a
petali bene lo fa adesso terza corsia
dall'alto cuffia bianca per l'azzurra la
finale paralimpica dei 100 stile libero
alla femminile categoria s11
partita partita la finale cecilia
camellini in corsia 3 è buona e buona la
partenza dell'azzurra che se la deve
vedere subito però contro liquidi che
cerca uno sprint nei primi 25 metri con
cecilia camellini che invece non molla
un centimetro camellini e gli alla
virata dei 50 ci presentiamo in questo
meraviglioso testa a testa
il passaggio che viene segnalato in 31 e
23 32 77 nettamente migliore la virata
di cecilia camellini
ora deve dare il tutto per tutto deve
sfruttare al massimo ed è così ha
guadagnato tantissimo spazio cecilia nei
confronti della cinese li guizzi il
parziale di gara per ora vede cecilia
camellini in prima posizione lanciata
verso la medaglia d'oro per la seconda
posizione combattono una staccata di una
lunghezza abbondante mary fisher e
librizzi sbandare finale cecilia
camellini ma riesce a mantenere il
vantaggio andiamo a prenderci la
medaglia d'oro bonacina cappellini e
abbiamo anche miliare il record del
mondo 107 e benji
e quindi dire apriamo la mente alle
alternative
il cuore alla passione perché solamente
così riusciremo a guardare oltre le
sconfitte perché sono loro che ci
insegnano a diventare migliori grazie
[Applauso]